all right welcome back so let's just
start from the top you're from where
originally and even then in LA about 15
years off and on 15 years yeah first
time it was ten and I back to Seattle
for a while and came back okay
and then again so currently you're not
dealing anymore you're rolling for them
yeah I work for all the drug dealers
right now yeah I used to sell but
there's too many problems
you gotta collect a beat people up it's
getting fights and it's just well a guy
he came to my area and he was just happy
to eat he just stores food down and make
the mess and I took I saw one of my
girlfriends so I'm picking up this dude
stuff after and I see him eat they chase
it throw this plate down I'd like dude
pick that [ __ ] up and throw the garbage
you know just gonna put homeless in he
has to be slobs [ __ ] you
is it but [ __ ] me dude pick your [ __ ] up
throw the garbage I'm gonna knock you
the [ __ ] out he's like whatever he says
laying on his blanket what are you doing
now he's like I'm going to sleep right
in front of my tent he's like yeah well
I was gonna let him sleep they're
walking kinky beverage never walk to
attend stomp on him I was never that
dude I told if anybody said anything
about me
in this area I've already hit you in the
mouth he's like go for it swung at me
dude I him twice to kill him broke his
neck snapped his brainstem he died
Kocher now the backs right here which is
the fact your Golden Gloves Jeff Freitag
will go to boxers and I also have
special forces so that please
automatically assume that I knew hitting
them in the mouth when stealin horses
hitched with RVs yeah I know how to
really really play yeah I don't even
like to fight but I know how to fight
yeah a little like you give me this yeah
yeah and you can take yours usually they
go like five six people with baseball
bats canes and stomach after me because
they know me they don't come with their
hands they go with knives baby bass yeah
six ten people towing can't sell any
more drugs because I'm taking all their
money yesterday when they hit you had to
move from one Street to another okay you
said well what happened was that
JT used to sell of spice this vibe from
him but he mix it with weed and I burned
a UA with the Viet with the best things
made me homeless so I got pissed off I
told you I'm not buying your crap
anymore
he said well there's nothing you do
about it I said really I went to the
source are buying spice then I hired
nine people started putting people in
different areas I started choking on his
supply pretty soon he was I would sell
all the spices he could sell one stick
business I'm getting everybody bit mad
so they finally ten I'm okay with
baseball bats that everything they told
me well I told you you can't sell it
there's only you can't sell our Crocker
to move to town
otherwise you know I asked why did you
bring a baseball bat they're like
because we know you I'm like all that I
moved to tell her so you don't yeah but
I joked about it in a military campaign
to choke a while I saw it six hundred
joints a day I end there if I wanted to
I could have completely put them out of
business but I let him go I live I let
him slide okay the side okay too many
fights to make elections in there too
damn a murder charge 15 years of life
over my head and it saved it was the
video game yeah it was on video thank
God if it wasn't our video that the guy
threw a punch I've been 15 to life in
prison
regardless and the guy started to fight
the guy made a mess the guy threw a
punch
he didn't matter I killed him made me
the bad guy understand so you didn't I
did I did 200 days and Counting 200 days
I did a year a drug rehab program and
I'm three years probation I got $11,000
or fines and restitution and I'll pay
for two punches either by the [ __ ]
funeral [ __ ] flowers for his [ __ ]
funeral
I faced $7,400 review flowers for this
baguette ass [ __ ] I can't even pay per
view for my wife when she died because
the county took all my [ __ ] I had her
cremated and you no longer able to deal
anymore so not you it's - I can't but I
don't want it because too much well
because if you get in any trouble you
have to if you have to collect from
somebody and get physical
yeah I'm gonna take trouble birth for
murder this time look real so your wife
passed away
yeah well see everything was going good
I was just about to buy a house to PB I
had what a Torrance just sold my house
the cars had two businesses buried Oh
everything was going good oh it's my
house come on huh and you say P via beer
from Palos Verdes did you say pals what
is it like get out of your fight hey
you're not from here you know you better
say P V if you're there yeah that's how
you know if you from there that's what
you have funny yeah hold on
I didn't sell drugs at first how about
two companies I had a computer company
Scott's PC and SoCal tools I sold tools
online I had two businesses two
successful businesses I own my own house
everything they took everything they
took a $500,000 a child's five hundred
thousand
it's four hundred thousand year old
taking me back anybody and just took my
money and said thanks for helping out a
kid that was it
she took all her stuff on Facebook all
of our conversations done
she said it me not my father I don't
want to know I really liked her too I
really wished she was my daughter but
she wasn't
I didn't have wipin I didn't have a
daughter either at that point that was
okay it kept me really alive the whole
time ins it is my daughter
I'm going across the Gulf of Alaska on a
boat I can swim faster the [ __ ]
is sailing into finally abyss I just I
want to jump I want to jump overboard
and she could swim around I was gonna
jump off the tail head and go right into
the big fan juice just kid shred it man
I was probably jumped into dolphin
jumping he almost hit me in the face on
the third tier dude I'm like what's a
freak me out
so outside of this boat was the moon on
the other side of the Sun I just about
jumped in and I knew if I went into the
propeller that's the only way I would
die then you want to do this because I
lost my wife lost everything did I even
care it more
if I didn't is this I know this is my
daughter or not I would have jumped I
would I done it that way but I had to
see this my daughter
yeah that was first and what I thought
that was my daughter's I was Sarge so my
wife your wife huh [ __ ] [ __ ] MA and all
the money I had I tried really nice
stuff really nice house really nice cars
everything I didn't give a [ __ ] about
that I miss my wife
that's ten years ago I still feel it put
me homeless Pony [ __ ] unemployed put
me in fully almost somewhere here yeah
and I can't move forward I can't I have
photographic memory I cannot get out of
my mind
people die over time okay no time
doesn't [ __ ] matter
I love through to death dude it doesn't
matter it's not enough time ever I'll
never ever not love her you know I've
never not hurt ten years [ __ ] feels
just like it happened yesterday
[ __ ] well it's hero time [ __ ]
[ __ ]
especially with a photographic memory oh
[ __ ] me I remember the smells I remember
clothes she was wearing I remember
everything before she died really bad
I booked out everything I own so I could
even see it but my first wife died
I got a burn permit burned out my house
everything she owned everything I don't
dude grab some clothes got my car drove
from Montana to Phoenix Arizona that's
why I moved first figure it off in a
fight that was it has 70 doctors Bobby
one of my ex-boyfriends boyfriend
she brought money for me and he said she
was gonna pay me I said you spoke about
[ __ ] - [ __ ] dude II hate him
dude and I'm gonna choke him but my hair
caught on fire this was melted right a
qualifier so I tried to lock him up but
I couldn't and I let go and he bit my
finger tried to bite it off yeah Cupid
enforcer I was beating him up each item
by my shoulder off in another fight
right there as a bite there's a bite but
my toxic levels were like 22.6 they're
like you're dead 23 Scoville toes the
doctor was like Maddie you had 21 yeah
so about the human valves are so dirty
if anybody bites you better go get
yourself fixed cuz you're gonna die
that's the worst mouth on the planet
except for a dragon dude I better get
bit by a rat or a dog that a person hell
yeah yeah yeah
hey guys bet it's chewed on a sewer pipe
because I got so much garbage about [ __ ]
that I was dying
all right 70 P word on two teams the red
team the blue team their life I couldn't
breathe myself on a tiny myself
i breather myself out died that's how
bad it was yeah I was fun
that beekeeper suit on using I saw like
I saw everything but I try to keep it
with just spice because that's just a
fraction there's a new drug yeah it's a
gateway drug between all crystal heroin
its crack it's a good gateway drug so
that wasn't really good if you sell that
you could make a ton of money anyway a
thousand dollars night every night no
problem I was gonna take over the Cuba
corner I didn't make three grands but I
had beat up some Cubans so right now as
addictive more bit more addictive than
any other drugs on the planet just my
heart because it's strong it's yes it's
strong hell they'll nod you just like
heroin it comes out between crystal
they'll bring you down to normal you
know meaning they'll bring it up from
crack as gateway drug it's perfect for
everything even even marijuana so I was
married for ten years to her and I
thought but she was really sick and I
told her to go to hospital find out
what's wrong you know she couldn't eat
couldn't swallow [ __ ] and they gave her
some a beautiful sulfated suffered said
she had emphysema I'm smoking and she
can't get worse I took her to another
her friend took her to another doctor I
told it break me out widow sulfate you
know tell you already been here this
ain't working go to step B she came back
with the same [ __ ] I said finally these
doctors I went into the hospital myself
to USC general I told the intake nurse
you better sit down and listen to me
right now my wife can't eat she this is
a day two day three she's dead
run every test you can do it find out
what the [ __ ] is going on with her you
know if I don't like what you're doing
I'll go to another hospital get it done
they found out she had terminal cancer
she was gonna die the intake nurse was
like man I remember you he said well you
said check everything new your words
were strong he said we did
I said your wife has got terminal cancer
and it's negative and I saw house good
he said no that's bad
I said what do you mean think it was
good isn't it that's a negative means
there's no cure
she's dead there's nothing that can do
positive means chemotherapy drugs
something worked put in remission
hers was negative which means she's dead
there's nothing another day three months
just like the nurse told me the doctor
lied to me said should she live for
years
they're all liars they just want your
money I pray the Cancer Institute of
Phoenix $300,000 one hundred thousand
dollars a month
she called me a couple of saying I want
to come home she's not hating here 700
thousand dollars a month you eat it are
you serious what those full man she said
bad people are here dying if they got
money the people are just waiting for
him to die slate ain't there money
nobody isn't something is so depressing
I said come on baby
she died week later yeah heart attack
her she had holes in her sock because I
paid for the undiscover'd the kaiser
permanente wouldn't approve it I have
paid fifteen thousand dollars out of my
own pocket for it they'd rather
endoscopy down the tube and camera down
up our holes her heart and lungs filled
up of water because she had holes in her
esophagus so every couple weeks you have
to have it drained take the pressure off
she was going in and she had a heart
attack and died
right I knew it - I knew it
there's nothing I can do about it
yeah my first pathway of a long time ago
yeah before her she wasn't gonna get
married again that wasn't ever gonna
imitate anybody ever again
my life I was married had a baby six
weeks old she both died in a car crash
you know my wife having baby both died
in a car crash
she was taking my baby to her mom's to
babysit we worked in Hamilton and I was
a little Laura she had a driver I had 62
I said she said you can't drive I told
her she's really tired I want to drive
you know she's like I'll just meet you
at work you're at 6:00 DUI yeah six
total yeah six soon I wanted to already
have three eight months to in Montana -
in Arizona I got one in a majority of
one someplace else I can't remember it
everywhere
what a jury that was a big one that six
total so she say you can't drive so I
was like okay so when you're going there
this is 40 miles of straight as there's
one curve before you get in town at
Hamilton there's a flower and every hits
them out so she died almost instantly
she missed the curve hits mountain just
like almost everybody
I was that working compare I went where
she was could buy that didn't show up to
work my boss told me tell your wife said
hospital is and I said what he's it he
would know what I tell me cuz you know I
run my production I eat him in the mouth
my truth to it an aquarium he had a
saltwater aquarium you see that windows
yeah he was mouth to a range of the
sales were just started beating his ass
people grabbed me pulled off knew I was
gonna kill him dude because he let me
worry buddy wife died in the hospital
while I was at work [ __ ] was I
didn't know where $80,000 worth of
damage to his requirements Mears I think
you see out but could see a dude I threw
him right through everything right was
just started pounding him dude my friend
Jim Allen st. but his life dude grab me
he's like 270 burn if you pull me off
dude I was gonna kill him dude I got to
the hospital they were both dead by the
time I got there I was so frustrated I
lost my job to can't hit your boss he
was too scared to fire me to him on fire
he's like they always let me keep my job
yeah cuz you didn't want me to be his
ass I was pissed don't you miss it that
long yeah but it's all going to change
it's all gonna change you know I mean
it's the reason for everything I mean I
must have done a bunch of bad stuff to
just remove all this stuff I got you
know how hopefully it's done what would
I pay it off yeah I see use is just
spice and crystal I do crystals some
heroin so every time I was doing
subtract but it's some cocaine but I
don't do weeders or fear any more
alcohol I'm Indian so my alcoholic and
I'm a Norwegian Viking so I get drunk
dude I go to jail Native American and
why he never Indian Viking so I get
drunk
I go to jail right away and so automatic
here I'm a berserker drunk you know so
we can't control ourselves you know and
I've know we did we go nuts
oh yeah that's scary everybody the whole
police department they like me in my own
special room do they everybody so they
all don't be there like oh god they
they'll put me with somebody else is
there they will actually lock me up and
put me in a separate isolation room with
lock they do the bed to keep other
people protected from me that's how
dangerous is he gonna have and you know
person few times yeah cuz I hire for
that burner charge is then I ran over a
cop pleasure involves broken ran it over
with my car he was talking [ __ ]
that's why popped him is about he just
say my word brothers where the [ __ ] I
said I'll tell you what look you bad
word ever drop he he said what why I'm a
pro please [ __ ] John [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] he lied about and I went to
backup this guy to escape my car he was
alright handcuffed us he had a [ __ ]
carburizing key to the [ __ ] party I
wear the clothes of Dorian shadow I was
late I backed out he followed the
[ __ ] gas station parking lot so I
slammed on the brakes that cop got up
tried to stop my car so I slammed on the
brakes he's gonna rip his arms off I ran
him over and shattered his hip
broke his leg Thank You placement
shattered his hip already broke his job
oh please I got sixty assaults at four
police officers one of my police officer
assaults two stories that was in a
female Hey
so they said I was gonna be buried but I
hired earnest lunch he's a six thousand
dollar an hour lawyer so he goes with
the district attorney as the judge on my
case so I got thirty thousand dollars in
fines restitution three years probation
720 hours of Caltrans work
I pick it up the freeway ball plug it
somewhere for three years ya know three
years I had Caltrans seven or twenty
hours anything I was gonna make is
community service cleaning up debris
under side of the road yeah instead of
me yep or community service Caltrans is
the worst one is worse they can be
serviced this is for running over the
cop now punch in his mouth run it over
watching him yeah shoot while you said
my word was more than [ __ ] I said I give
my word I'm gonna drop you said what put
him to sleep I think your job is to
protect and serve God harass and annoy
[ __ ] dude you're pissing me the
[ __ ] off what [ __ ] I like it like
what sighs even the cops are weak it's
oh we got all the bumps I got this big
big crazy Club
Chester type thing I could throw it
right through this cop cars cruiser I
said you said put on Zeke move your
[ __ ] fruits or do decide ho please
don't throw it through my car he said
well he said I know you're gonna do it
to me so I'll move my car I said but I
had the whole thing I'll do I was just
slamming through his car everybody knows
me there's a me the cops don't matter
like he's nuts just move your car who
regard his way but after it took me
about seven years in that kind of
reputation at first I couldn't smell
anything anywhere to anyone you got an
earned respect and then you could do it
dying so anything I want anywhere I want
I just don't feel like it right now if
you want to quit
start your life over you could do it I
could do that 15 years ago
yeah I could have I just don't want to
yeah there's nothing for me to do
anymore I've done everything
no I got rich I've been married I've
been loves all businesses I've done
everything
been everywhere seen everything y'all
this is a dead end it's gonna take you
down eventually
so matter no matter if I die that's the
purpose I some rest finally get a rest
from all this [ __ ] no go to heaven just
God's ask for [ __ ] eternity it's up
no I want [ __ ] that I'm not gonna do it
I want to die when I die
yeah I want to die when I die I want to
be - that's it I don't want it [ __ ]
she's God's ask for eternity and bastard
heaven [ __ ] all that I want to die
period